>>> HELLO,VEE.U SO MAND PPW ARI.
ALASKA ALI G
OF BOEING
HAD JUSTAN OF
PORTLAND,  A CABIN RF,EAVING
ONE PASSENGER CAPTURED THE SCENE
DURINGY TENSE SILENT
MOMENTS AFTER THE INCIDENT
HAPPENED.
THEY'RE ALNEN  THERE.
T UTES BORTHR
LANDING
BACK IPORTLAND.
A PASSENGER DESCRIBES THE ORNDSE
PANEEWYOE
LATER THERE WAS A IOTHAT'S ABOU
REFRIGERATORDSS HIGH.
SHE SAID, GUESS, BOY
MOTHER WAS SITTING THERE THAT
S SHIR OFF
M  THE PLANE, AND
HIS MOTHER WAS ONT
SHE SAID HERY'S WENT O TOO.
INCREPETE MUNTEAN IS TRACKING A
LATEST DENTSATWE KNOW W THIS
>> THIS HAPPEN
EXPLOSE , LIKEENT CONVERTIBLE RE
A BOEING MAX IERVE BEE
, KNOWN AS A DOOMI TLIGHT  FEET
EXRILLY
AS AAPOM.
THE HIGH PRESSURTHABLE AIR GG IM
BOY WHO
S  OFF.OXYGEN MWN.PILOTSITH THI
QUICKLY., FLY THWO, RUN THCHDEST
.
[IND]
>> WHEGIVE ME TH
ND YOUISRN
>> WE NEEDO DESCEND DO HR E PIL
THEIR MUFFLED IC.
KEY HAD KS O
'S
IT DEPENDS OG ERE E HE BOEING CT
NF THE
AIINANE, IN PARTICULAR, T ATE O
PLANE TH PNE R
OFF THY FLOOR ONLY
WEEKS AGO.
FIT , OCTOBE.150 FLHTR
BO N THE MICROSCOP LITANY OFITT
PEOPLE KILLED,RO8 MONTHS PASSENN
BO S ALL OKAY.
THE CREW D AN EXCEPTIONAL JOB.
THE.IS IATA OF PEOPLE. IA GREATS
ANS NOW THAT OTHER
AIR 737
IS LATES.
THEY SAY 215 737
MAX 9s IUS THE.R COMMEN
ALKA5 OF ITSANES ARE ALL TEMPOR
THIS SPECIC SPOTWE WILL SEE WHA.
THE NTSBO THIS ALONG
WITH THEAA YOUNG
JUST TEN WLD.
PEANYOU SO MUCH.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO HEAR A Y
FALL OFF, GEED AD
FRENF PEOPLE?
FLABBERGASTED.
R ME TREGARD O THAT
ALASKA DOES ORUTILIZCULAR SEIOE.
THAT WAS A SERVICE DOOR.
PETE DID A GREAT JOB OF
BI END OF THE DAY, IT'S
PLUG-TYPE DOOR, IS WHAT WE CALL.
E NK VAULT.
THAT DOOR,F  W USED AS AN EXIT,
SEALED TIGHT AT
AIRPLANE.
HOW IT
TR JOB.MABLE TO ME. THE CREDID
THE FIRSG YOU'VE G TO DO
E CAREYOE VEE DOS
PUT ON OURN MASK WONLYT 16
IT WOULD HAVE GO
HAD THEY BEE LONGER ORH HIGH
ONCE YOU STARTTHE OXYGENT CHECK
THEN YOU CY QUICKLY. CAVTS OF C
DOWN IS TO SAY, WELLOULD WE
D DE
POSSIB SRAGUESS WHATTH
A CALLM FLIGHT O SAY, HEY, THE E
HEELS
IN
LYA LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME THAN THEY WOULD
HAVE.
WHEN I LOOAT THE FLI, THEY
DOWN A L BUT I T
THEY WERE USING THEIR BEST
JUDGMENT, AND A
HARROWING SITUATION FOR TH
>>E CEATE .T COMES TOHENASIS OF
THE  MENTIONEDSEAL
THIS IS ACE WHERE THERE'S AN
OPE WINDOWS.CASE, YOU SAID IUG
TRADITIONALLY AROUND IT?AT BE  .
Y WENT WRONG.THIS
WHAT'S THE FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS IN TRYIO FIGURE OUTY TS
COMPROMI
SERVICE DOOR, WHICH WOULD BECOME
AN EMERGENCY EXIT, LIKE I SAID,
THE SEAL IS JUST TO E T SURROUN.
ALL OFSO HAVIN DOOR COME OPEN
REPLE,MAZINGHAT COULD
HAPPEN WASN'T PROPERLYD IF TDOO
TIWA
COCKPIT WOULD HAN A
AG, THIS
DOOR IS OPENO IT'S WISE,N YO
THATMM KINDS ORAFTS, PART OF FL
WOULD BE C THE
A TEAM TO
ND TO INVESTIGATE FROM
ND IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY RCUMSTG
IT.
LET'S NOT START TALKING ABOUT
THE ORHE M
THTAINLY ISN'T RELATED TO
THM CAST
BUT LIKE PETSAIDTHERE
THISPLUALITY CONTROL
PING THA GETRIGHT, OR THIS ILY,
THIS IS ONOFN THAT
COULVE
RE AWARE O
AT THIPOINT.
>> IS IT A
OF DOOR O
COIG
IAN
NEED T ISKIND OTI O
FTS?
>> WE SHN' CONCERN.
ORDER THEIR
FERENT TYPES O
IT COMES TOITOARR.
UNUSUAL FROM THAT
ES DECIDED HAVE ENOUGH A
EMERGENCY EVON SITUATION,  DIDN
DOOR,O THEYG. O